[Musique]
c'est au son est sur le rythme de la
musique brésilienne que la capuera a
trouvé son origine à mi chemin entre le
sport de combat et la danse cette
pratique puiss s racine de la culture
afro-brésilienne les origines de la CAB
c'est le Brésil voilà et à l'époque le
Brésil c'est au niveau de l'esclavage
pour déguiser qu'il se qu'ils
apprenaient à se battre en fait il
faisaent comme s'il dansaient illusions
en disant enlevant la jambe un petit peu
comme si donc les les esclavagistes
pensaient que c'est qu'il dansaient et
en fait ils apprenaient à se battre et
c'est comme ça qui est née la capoera
pratiqué partout dans le monde la
capouera a commencé à se développer dans
les ivines il y a une vingtaine d'années
mare touché est arrivé en France et a
voulu développer l'URE de la capera
parce qu'il a vu qu'il y en avait pas
ici donc il a développé la capuera et en
fait en mettant un petit peu quelques
pierres à l'édifice ça s'est développé
en prenant en faisant des manifest
estation à l'extérieur en faisant des
démonstrations c'est ainsi qui est né
l'une des premières écoles du territoire
Bell horizonté capera situé à hancour
j'is en France à la fin 2 2002 c'était
un peu la passion déjà j'ai travaillis
déjà au Brésil j'ai travaillais des
autres villes autres pays aussi en
Suisse donc quand j'ai arrivé c'était la
mort et tous les adhérents que j'ai
conquir aujourd'hui il sont là des
petits j grand plus un sport de combat
c'est toute une culture à la fois
historique et musicale que cette
pratique
[Musique]
diffuse ultime consécration pour les
capouéristes le passage de cordes un
moment symbolique qui récompense
l'investissement des sportifs les grades
ça représente
l'évolution de du capoiriste dans dans
son parcours depuis quelques années les
écoles de capuera fleurissent dans les
ivelines de quoi promettre encore un bel
avenir à cette discipline vieille de
plusieurs
siècles